I knew we had a meeting today I just  kind of started binge watching that show  about medieval cops which is dope snacks  Red Bull you can do it good  brainstorming tell me you were loving  this puffy paint right I added it this  morning and it's the best and I really  think it makes our visuals pop i  [Music]  collated and copied the notes from our  last meeting as well as email them to  everyone in bullet points so you guys  really don't have an excuse not to be  able escape I mean yes totally yes I did  see that I believe I didn't open it  has anyone heard from Randy you didn't  RSVP so do we know if I can get some  help outlining these borders in marker  that would be awesome  let's do this  [Music]  [Music]  hey Study Group's sorry I am late home I  missed it  Oh snacks score